Debbie you have fans have you noticed
how many people love you
well it's kind of daunting it's like I
love people and I I love their kindness
and I really appreciate that because
sometimes we live in an unkind world
yeah for sure well did you apply to be
on the show how did this come about
actually
it came about I applied for the show
almost as a joke an afterthought and I
thought oh this would be funny and then
I told Osama it's like hey guess what I
applied for this this crazy show and it
sounds like you know it suits us because
we kind of like have an odd relationship
that's not really traditional and I
thought well maybe if it could help
someone else you know that's that's uh
struggling with ageism or depression I
said maybe it can help someone and at
first Osama said no I don't think so and
then later he said yeah why not you know
there are people who love you but of
course you have others who have negative
things to say so how have you been
dealing with the opinions of so many
people it's you know from The
Superficial the first glance at me and
Osama yeah it might look like oh she's a
purpose oh she's a latch oh she's a
cougar oh she's a granny cougar you know
I've heard it all and it's like you know
I'm just miss Debbie I'm a kind person
I'm not looking for any young man I
thought I have an old one man but guess
what there's no old man out there
they're either dead or they're married
you know my pool for for finding a nice
man is very small actually it's a little
mud puddle it's not even a pool I met
Osama on social media he commented about
my artwork well let's get into unusama
and not for once you didn't think that
he had ulterior motives or
he was trying to take advantage of you
well you know it's like like any person
that is uh well read or watches TV
there's always like oh is this guy you
know am I a catfish or is he a catfish
it's like to me I didn't even know what
a real catfish was because it's like to
me it's hard to put on the mental
thinking tap of using someone because I
wouldn't do that so it was hard for me
to relate to that concept but yeah I
realize there's stuff going on to where
people are doing mean things to other
people but I said oh no a man with
disintelligence and knowledge of Art and
poetry he couldn't be like catfishing me
my name is Usama is 24 years old and
eleven tennis
on all my works there's about sadness
Melancholy misery I'm I mean all the
things can help to humans let's talk
about your personalities he seems to be
more so of a loner and
you know might dab a little bit in in
darkness or enjoy he enjoys creating art
um from dark perspectives and you seem
to be more light-hearted and with a
positive attitude and free spirited so
do your personalities Ever Clash I felt
at home with Osama because I knew from
how he spoke to me in his dark side that
he had suffered through some depression
and possibly some bullying or something
and I wanted to lift him up because I
could relate to that you know I I self
-isolated myself and put myself in a
this is what I want to say I put myself
in an exile a self-imposed Exile because
the world was too hurtful and too
painful to deal with and then I found
that in Osama too so I said well gee
whiz let me kind of like help him out of
it and let him see that there is
lightness because he he did tend to get
dark sometimes but then he got way
better and he even said that you know I
brought light into his life yeah that's
beautiful Debbie so you have been
through a lot you opened up about your
childhood growing up my mother had some
significant mental health issues
I never knew any kind of normalcy or
structure
how did you come out of that dark space
that 12 years of Exile how did you
re-emerge
the devil you are today it was due to
Osama his kindness and you know what
every person
is sometimes starving for that empathy
Osama offered some empathy and kindness
and and love that you know as far as I
wasn't finding in my community and
that's sad to say and and that's why
right now
I want to do more with people that
struggle with depression or have uh
mental illness and it's like anxiety I
mean people are stressed out and we need
someone to throw us a lifesaver I know
that there is a Madness inside of me
that I showed in my poetry and in my
painting Osama also mentioned that he
has Madness inside of him and the way he
expresses it is art does that ever
concern you
um his darker side or the madness he
might have in him yes he is often
mentioned that he has some kind of
Madness and then he even tells me Debbie
you have holy Madness and it's like it
became kind of a catch phrase but I
understood him to be kind of like the
lone wolf in his community and like he
didn't have like what we have Avenues to
explore your talents and you know some
place to go and talk to people they
don't have like therapy over there and
they probably did you'd probably be
running out of town for trying to get
therapy but I'm all about you know
supporting artists and people that have
been hurt and stepped on by society and
people that have clicks can be very
vicious and it's like I wanted to Osama
to like Bloom as a person because he had
been downturner such as myself
so it sounds like you trust his nature
because I can assume if Julian your son
heard him saying that he has Madness
inside of him you can just imagine all
these worst case scenarios that could
you know happen from that
well Julian like you know is a very
logical cop man's man type guy and he
doesn't have a lot of finesse when it
comes to emotions and discovering your
inner self and things like that whereas
I understand
Osama and his struggles but Osama you
know is basically a very good person
he's just misunderstood he's just had a
lot of hard times and times that you
know we're kind of uh ignorant about and
it's like I want I'm I'm here I miss
Debbie for uplifting people but I I
never got the chance because I was
wallowing in my own depression but now
and then when I saw in Osama it's like
okay I can help you fix yourself too and
we can both make each other strong
longer and we can in turn be a good
example for other people that are
suffering do you feel like if Osama was
to leave or you two were to break up do
you feel like you'll still have that you
know strength that you've cultivated and
that joy that you've cultivated if he's
no longer there well that's tough to say
because you know
haven't a strong relationship for
someone for over four years now you
develop a solid Bond and I'm a very
loyal person
and uh very trusting too and it's like
but I was careful this time I said to
myself you know no one's going to pull
anything shady on me anymore I've had
enough Shady stuff done to me my whole
life so I said Osama he's gonna be that
that Prince that Prince Charming you
know and he's going I'm going to help
him and he's going to help me and it's
like and my son doesn't get that but I
do and you know yeah yeah I'm older I
get that but it's like this is something
other than just age you know this is
something important to the intrinsic
nature of a human being to survive and
to flourish
I completely understand that and I am
curious you don't have to answer this
but is your relationship do you all get
intimate or is it just strictly
helping one another and loving and being
romantic in that way
well Osama has tried yeah you know it's
like he's he's a red-blooded man it's
like he's tried but when I say no guess
what he respects me and then he's very
romantic he does all the right things
and he's just wonderful as far as the
most romantic guy I've ever been with in
my life and plus he's a gentleman you
know most guys you know it's all about
grabbing and whatever and it's like you
know it's like yeah Osama has his
moments but he knows when no means no
and then he goes back to being the
gentleman I feel comfortable with Gods
sometimes more than people because God's
of Silence I like to walk in the farm
because you know reduce you and animals
and your father
he likes silence so my question for you
you seem to like to talk do you ever
feel the need to be quiet around Osama
well you know it's funny you say that
because you know it's like when it's
like Osama yes he is a quiet man but
sometimes you know with me just being a
motor mouth sometimes he kind of looks
fascinated and he gets his his mind
going in another Direction it's like
maybe maybe I'm a distraction a good
distraction for him and he listens to
and and more importantly I listen to
what he has to say and yeah sometimes
he's a man of few words but you know we
he can text me the most beautiful poetry
and it's like oh I get him so much he
keeps everything locked up inside and he
gave me the key he said Miss Debbie got
the key to osama's Heart how do you know
he's not scamming you
I know because in all this time he has
never asked for money
not yet one of julianierson's concerns
though is that he could potentially be
using you for your money now although
Osama probably has not asked you for
money do you still offer it or give it
to him considering that he doesn't have
a job you know I feel when you love and
care about a person you want them to
have good things in their life so yeah
I've sent him money for groceries I send
him money to Veterinary money for his
cat it's like compassionate things a
person you know would do those
compassionate things but there's no like
over the top big bucks you know it's
just a little here and there and I did
buy him a skateboard for a present
because you know he was going to teach
me to skateboard too it's like I'm
looking forward to learning how to do
the skateboard it's like you know it's
like there's a kid inside of me that
just can't wait to go and have some fun
for a change wait Debbie you're going to
learn how to skateboard you got to be
careful out there
well you know I I can uh bring the elbow
pads and the knee guards but yeah all of
that yeah I'll do all the safety things
but it's like who says you gotta stop
living when you get old you know agent
just the number
foreign